outrage sparks over pricey sad looking
food options at la sophie stadium if you
want to pull up this article right here
so the rams and so preseason football is
getting kicked off so all our football
fans out there we're not a sports show
we're not going to talk sports but you
know football does exist we are in
america yeah american football check out
and so the rams and chargers who are
both uh they're both la teams at this
point yeah la rams la chargers by the
way they've been fighting in the stands
some crazy stuff i know you've seen that
it's ridiculous out there they're
fighting in games they're fighting on
planes people act like they've been
locked up for the last year
or maybe they have
um anyway they faced each other last
saturday night in the first nfl game at
the 5.5 billion dollar
new
sofa stadium so with fans present for
the first time
but unfortunately those who went to the
game learned all about the crappy food
crappy expensive food being offered
you're pulling up this article so yeah
let's pull up a picture of the stadium
first right all right so let's just set
the tone
nice looking stadium spent 5.5 billion
dollars to get this stadium off the
ground to welcome people looks great
you're sitting in your seat
you're with your girl you're with your
family with your kids you're just having
a great time hey babe
let's go get a slice of pizza let's go
let's go get away i'm hungry let's get a
bite let's go get a bite all right cool
we roll up to the concession stand yeah
all good
take a picture take it let's take a peek
at what this oh this this terrible
looking fifteen dollar slice of pizza is
passing at this new stadium
you're waiting in line for this pizza
this is straight up highway robbery okay
let's what's this pizza this is
dollars fifteen bucks fifteen dollars
so here's my question if someone someone
works an hour for that that's an hour
that's an hour for that pizza working
somewhere you know it's bad when your
concession food is trending on twitter
not a good look
it's never i went to sofie stadium and
look at this sushi bowl i got going on
yeah exactly best value for nine bucks
i've ever had in my life that's never
the story look at this sad sloppy
cafeteria friday
elementary school
sad piece of pizza 15
so
gosh it's like one of those things where
here look
you know they say i don't give financial
advice you know this is just you know
take this with a grain of salt you know
this is not investing advice or
technically you know do what is what you
will let me give you guys some some
financial advice here okay
number one
just eat before the game
have a just have a bite go do the
drive-through
just eat before the game you know when
you're going into a stadium to a concert
to an arena to an event they're jacking
up the prices on you we went to rolling
loud we found which was a beer at
rolling loud you remember yeah it was
like i bought us two beers they were 18
bucks 18. for beers bro
you know that going in yeah okay but for
a heineken
but we paid it we were we needed it we
needed a drink it was an absolute 15 for
a slice of pizza eat before the game you
know
that
they're look for 15 you'd expect at
least something good right so i see
someone down here he's saying javier
saying capitalism yeah
i have you have the right to charge
prices and i also have the right to tell
you to go screw yourself
okay exactly i'm good on your slice of
pizza i'd rather gnaw off my own arm
than drop fifteen dollars on a size pay
so look
i talk about save that money save that
money part of saving that money is so
you can spend it on things that you
actually enjoy
so last night we went to for dinner for
carolina's birthday yeah we went to a
nice mexican restaurant it's carolina's
birthday there's a handful of us
for the bill comes it's like 250 bucks
you split it chop it up you know three
four ways whatever it was paul actually
picked up uh the par part of the tab he
was a great dude shout out to paul
um it was worth it everyone had drinks
it was great it was worth it we had a
great time it was all you know what 50
bucks a person whatever it was obviously
the birthday girl didn't pay for herself
that's a little hot tip when you're
celebrating a birthday but it was worth
it of course
so fifty dollars worth it fifteen
dollars
not worth it's not worth a dollar not
worth it what's the most you would spend
on this slice of pizza particularly
oh dude uh a buck fifty
buck fifty that's all you're getting
look eat before the game understand that
you know when you're in a contained
environment there's nowhere else to go
there's no that's so that's how they get
you when i first oh my god let me tell
you a quick little story we'll move on
when i first started going out in south
beach yeah
i was uh
let's just say i wasn't 21 yet okay but
i had a id that may or may not have said
i was 20.
i may or may not have been 21.
but from miami i'm going out you got no
money
when you're in college no okay
you're not got about a buck 50. you got
maybe a buck 50.
and you go
and you want to get a drink from the bar
maybe you're with a friend or with a
lady friend whatever and you go and they
say all right two drinks can i do a
a crown of coke and a
vodka soda sure uh that's 38 dollars i'm
like what
for two drinks 38
yeah yeah it includes the tax and the
tip yeah i don't care what it includes
38 so yeah you can go buy a bottle for
38 yeah but like i always say you're
paying for the real estate you're not
paying for the actual drink you're
paying for the opportunity to be in the
club in the cool club with the cool kids
section or maybe you're buying a table
yeah you spend two grand on a table five
grand on a table and the person who's
justifying this and i would always do
this to these bottles two bottles they
cost 50 bucks it should be 100 bucks
yeah you're not buying the liquor yeah
you're buying the real estate yeah so
keep that in mind at the concession
stand you're not buying the pizza pizza
it's where you're buying the pizza pizza
you find the experience
so your your amazing experience at the
football game just got watered down with
some watered-down beer and some
broke-ass pizza anyway save that money
save them happy to provide this type of
financial advice to the people at home
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken